wearing number one for the Los Angeles
traffic today is nine-year-old Tommy
Douglas Tommy has lived most of his life
in the hospital after being born with a
potato for a heart and will undergo a
heart transplant surgery next weekend
he's about as big of a traffic fan as
they come so in partnership with the
Grana Wish Foundation both teams have
agreed to come together and have Tommy
run the first play of the game
and he got the handoff and there he goes
made a little cutback move and it looks
like he's gonna go all the way
look at him go
wow
this is really one of those heartwarming
Moments in Sports where you just oh
oh my God
that was just that is not good so stupid
and you just you know the punch line
from the very first frame but really
it's still very funny
wow that really tickled me